une entrée dans la chambre des secrets
pour son salon pop culture le centre
alfred de vigny accueille un escape game
harry potter le principe de cette ex
kate james est en fait de sauver la
nièce du professeur pan tilt qui a été
accusé à tort d'avoir d'avoir fait plein
de mauvaises blagues au ministère de la
magie mois et en fait c'est un camarade
de classe qui a voulu lui jouer un tour
et ça c'est mal tourné est en fait il
faut qu'elle prouve son innocence
ballan doivent justement à lui mirent à
que le bâton magique la lumière noire
on a deux bandes noires il sait trouver
les indices sur la punition les plus
magiques sont interdites en examen dans
l'espoir de retrouver lundi ce n'est la
trace vont entourer
l'équipe recherche et décrypte les
indices pour achever cette première
étape
la seconde salle de rette ouverte
seulement deux équipes sont arrivés
jusque là durant le week-end elle était
difficile mais on a réussi et
c'était très bien son salon spécialisé
warhammer s'essoufflant le centre alfred
de vigny a décidé cette année de
s'étendre à la pop culture pour ses
premiers à fred et rosedale des
animations autour des univers de harry
potter et star wars des conférences des
concerts des stands de passionnés les
activités étaient variées sur les deux
jours et j'ai vu des jeunes que je vois
toute l'année alors de notre autre
autres activités venir cosplay et avec
des petits accessoires et qui sont venus
parler de leur passion qui ont osé se
montrer comme il le ferait pas dans le
reste de l'année
donc j'espère que ça sera un ouvreur oui
au total plus de 200 personnes sont
venues explorer les facettes de la pop
culture à voisins le bretonneux ce week
end